what about um
comparisons to to Pete Davidson you
didn't enter out on that I've gotten
that a lot yep uh I think it started in
2014 or 15. I did the it was on
intentional talk yeah and someone they
asked like if you ever
get any comparisons and that was like
before Pete kind of took off he was
still he was on SNL still but he was
kind of just starting out
um
and they set it on there and then it
kind of got back to him and he came out
the city field and we played the Mets
there dressed up
um as me and kind of took PP which they
didn't tell anybody that he was coming
so like the the strength coach was
running stretch was like who's this guy
like no they didn't know you're so young
because the Marlins didn't tell anybody
that he was showing up they just like
rolled him out there and they thought it
was like a plan or something so what's
the what's the weird have you ever had
like a weird place that you were like oh
that's Pete Davidson no one's ever come
up to me and thought I was like actually
Pete but
every night we play Somebody's screening
so that Pete Davidson at me especially
on the road do you see it or no are you
like I don't know he I've I've met him a
few times and he he knows about like
because he gets it a little bit or he
used to get a little bit too
um we kind of both agree that we don't
really look too much like each other so
you're off base on Pete Davidson
probably yeah okay